welcome to whatever this is
[Music]
[Applause]
our main story tonight concerns
immigration the system that brought you
me but it's still good and a promise
that won't happen again last month some
idiot paid a hundred and six dollars for
possibly the largest raisin bran flakes
in the world and let me just say that
idiot is very happy with his purchase
[Applause]
winter even got you to legalize medical
marijuana which means that in the not so
distant future there is a genuine chance
that Mitt Romney could be lying on a bed
stoned out of his mind
giggling and asking his wife do you
think we have like too many sons dad
Jeff we can buy points fines catarah
stats long bonds latter this is a
pyramid scheme spending good money on a
pony made wax figure of a former
president sounds pretty stupid right I'm
proud to say we bought five
[Applause]
you believe there could be an infinite
number of parallel universes does that
mean that there was a universe where I
am smarter than you
[Music]
[Applause]
that's our show
you